hello Anderson here oh hello my name is
Adam Smith calling from nobelprize.org
the website of the Nobel Prize in
Stockholm congratulations on the award
the Nobel Prize thank you very much how
did you hear the news and I'm at a
meeting about cryo-em in Leicester
University so I'm just in the session
listening to people speaking so my phone
rang in the meeting and I had to go out
of the room the lecture room to to hear
it and by then the reception had been
cut off a couple of times but eventually
after about five minutes I managed to
get through and then I chatted to guna
Vaughn hai ji who I knew first yes then
three other people from the Nobel Prize
Committee for that and then they told me
that the chemistry prize was going to be
awarded with jacques du bois che and
yoke and Frank of course I know very
well so I think that's quite delightful
really of course there are a few other
people who also contributed but I think
all of us know that the the Bell Prize
and awards are always usually only two
to three people so they're often one or
two others who've made strong
contributions who didn't quite cross the
threshold the meeting is a wonderful
environment to hearing because imagine
that everybody will be celebrating today
it's quite a small meeting nice for a
celebration you were the first to
achieve atomic resolution of
biomolecules with cryo-em what does it
allow you to see what detail can we now
see that we couldn't see before
I think the first structures of
biological molecules were by x-ray
crystallography back in 1959 1960 with
John Kendrew who had a chemistry Nobel
Prize to work on myoglobin and
developing the x-ray method and since
we've had over the last 50 years
hundreds of Oh at least a hundred
thousand structures done by x-ray
crystallography and so in a way try uem
is just an
other method of finding out what the
atomic structure high-resolution
structure of your molecules are but the
difference is that there are quite a lot
of structures and biology that were
resistant were recalcitrant to the other
methods like x-ray crystallography or
nuclear magnetic resonance spectroscopy
so it's opened up essentially a kind of
new previously unapproachable area of
structural biology and I think my
original work was working on membrane
proteins which we found difficult to
crystallize the real power has come from
the images where you don't need crystals
so you just take a picture you look at
it you process it your average stretches
when you get there so it's a much more
direct method than making crystals
getting diffraction spots and then
figuring out what the diffraction spots
means so I think it's it's a direct
method easy to understand and much more
general in its power and what you can
use it for thank you this is another
Nobel Prize for the MRC LMB for
structure determination it seems that
it's specialness continues what is it
that makes it such an extraordinary
place I think it's got long term support
from the Medical Research Council and I
see this is the hundred and fifth year
that the UK Medical Research Council has
been supporting either medical or
biomedical or biology related to
medicine structural work and they've got
a lot of experience in managing groups
units or Institute's and actually
they've been quite bold in terms of
supporting new ideas and she was closing
down other areas that have fulfilled
their purpose the MRC molecular biology
lab in Cambridge
of course benefited greatly from the
people who founded it back in the late
fifties so Max Perutz was the original
first head then he called himself a
chairman and he was very good at
recruiting people allowing them to
follow their own ideas in depth and so
that's culture has permeated throughout
the labs but since it started and that's
I mean there have been little gaps but
periodically there have been Nobel
Prizes for all sorts of different things
actually yes it's been a very successful
lab and I obviously I went there as a
student I've been there for 51 years or
something like that so you know I've
certainly absorbed the culture and
helped to try and propagate it well how
nice to find such a good home they say
there's a Nobel laureate on every floor
of the LMB and now they have another
quite a lot of them have retired now but
who knew and I asked him partly retired
we very much look forward to working you
to Stockholm in December will you be
coming oh yeah looking and sure I can
change it
well once again congratulations and it's
not due to speak to you thank you any
thanks then thank you